today the matt walsh show it went
largely unnoticed but last week the
biden administration officially proposed
changes of title ix that would legally
erase women and they did this even as
they scream about alleged attacks on
women's rights we'll talk about that
also horror at the border as 50 people
are left to die in the back of a truck
after being smuggled across the border
this is what compassionate open borders
policies gets you and camilla harris
launches into a transphobic rant in
response to roe you have to hear this to
believe it awful stuff plus more
celebrities threaten us with a good time
by promising to leave the country
because roe was overturned in our daily
cancellation we review the work of
acclaimed best-selling poet laureate
amanda gorman all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
that summer vacation that you've planned
is uh expensive on its own but now let's
add in the higher cost of gas and credit
card fees which are already close to 19
are expected to rise again soon it's
becoming impossible to save any money to
enjoy some time away after all your hard
work this year don't let all those
expenses ruin all of your plans instead
save some money and get a free mortgage
review from our friends at american
financing let a salary based mortgage
consultant talk to you about custom
loans that can fit your budget better
i mean it from your home loan to your
equity and even your high interest debt
they'll review all of it with you and
they will do everything they can to help
you save up to a thousand dollars a
month those are huge savings and you can
help you afford that dream summer
vacation and afford so much else if
you're ready to save up to a thousand
dollars a month all you got to do is
pick up the phone and give them a call
if you start soon you could skip two
payments and may close in as fast as 10
days just call 866
569-4711 that's 866-569-4711
or visit americanfinancing.net
nmls18234 nmls consumeraccess.org
well the left can take solace in the
fact that the recent sanity and
restraint of the supreme court will be
counteracted by the recklessness lunacy
and blatant criminality of the dementia
administration in fact biden's hhs
secretary xavier becerra announced
yesterday that the white house will
likely start providing tax-funded
transportation
uh to people seeking out-of-state
abortions now
is that actually legal is it legal for
the federal government to use tax money
to pay to ship people across state lines
to get abortions because it's illegal in
their state well the legality of it is a
small detail of course but here was um
becerra's answer listen to this
what are you doing concretely in
response to the court's decision to try
to help women well we're working with
centers like planned parenthood so we
are
restoring funding for
title 10
family planning services we are working
with
supporters on the ground to make sure
that we are providing services to women
where we can uh we are looking into
everything including assisting in
transportation something that hhs
doesn't typically do can you do that
legally
talk to me later uh
that's a big question right i always
tell my team at hhs uh
if you've done your homework then we
have no right to do mild and so we're
gonna be aggressive and go all the way
and i i would tell you if uh
you're recording so i won't tell you
this is all on the record mr secretary
we are looking at every option and among
those is transportation
say that again we are looking at every
option and among those is transportation
transporting women to other states
[Applause]
hilarious let's all have a nice laugh at
the government official openly declaring
his intention to break the law and it's
guaranteed that everyone in the audience
plus the two people on stage
have frequently claimed that trump
donald trump was undermining and
destroying our democracy through illegal
activity that nobody could ever exactly
specify or prove but the biden
administration can make a joke out of
their criminality and the same people
simply laugh
this is what happens when party loyalty
eats your brain now speaking of breaking
the law
amid all of the celebration last week
the bite administration
did something else rather amid the the
conservatives celebrating uh the the
rightful conservatives celebrating
there's something the bite
administration did amid all of that that
uh should attract much more notice than
it has so far
the day before the road decision was
announced only 24 hours before the left
dissolved into apoplectic rage screaming
that women were being murdered and so on
the buying administration proposed
illegal changes to the law with the
intention
of officially erasing women so they
erased women and then a day later were
accusing the other side of erasing women
uh by overturning roe v wade now the law
is title nine
and before we can talk about what biden
is doing to title ix and with it uh
today we need to backtrack a bit i think
and lay some groundwork so title ix has
been really in many ways destructive and
intentionally confusing since its
inception
as it originally appears in the higher
education amendments of 1972 title ix
simply states that quote
no person in the united states shall on
the basis of sex be excluded from
participation in be denied the benefits
of or be subjected to discrimination
under any education program or activity
receiving federal financial assistance
now that sounds clear enough right and
it's it's hard to argue with the
underlying principle a a public
federally funded institution should be
open to everybody and nobody should be
excluded based simply on their sex
sounds simple but then again a statement
like the right of the people to keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed also
sounds pretty clear and straightforward
and simple and yet politicians and
bureaucrats have found ways of obscuring
that point and the same happened with
title ix and it happened almost
immediately
the first consequence intended or
unintended
was that under the guise of title ix
men's athletic programs across the
country were shut down hundreds of them
at a time it was decided that the
prohibition on excluding people on the
basis of sex meant somehow that every
university must have an equal number of
men's and women's sports teams and an
equal number of male and female athletes
and this absurd quota system was
codified into law
while codified bureaucratically anyway
as presidential administrations just
began adding to title ix legislation
even though adding to or amending
legislation is supposed to be a power
reserved for the legislative branch and
by the time of the clinton
administration um the assault on men's
sports we got to women's sports the
assault on women's sports later but uh
originally was an assault on men's
sports and by the time we got to clinton
administration of the 90s this this
assault was well underway uh
universities that could not conjure up
enough female athletes to match the
number of male athletes had to start
shutting down male sports teams for the
sake of compliance
of course what these quota systems never
took into account is that men tend to be
more interested in sports than women and
people in general right tend to be more
interested in watching men's sports than
in watching women's sports and all of
this adds up to a perfectly rational
non-discriminatory non-sexist reason for
colleges to have more male athletes and
to spend more money on male sports
but too bad said the bean counters make
it equal make it 50 50 no matter what it
takes
at the same time the issue of a sexual
harassment got tangled up in the title
ix enforcement web
now once again in principle
everyone agrees that sexual harassment
is bad and should be punished seems
pretty simple
but title ix says nothing at all about
sexual harassment or sexual assault the
law simply
doesn't
you know it's not meant to to deal with
that problem because not every law can
deal with every problem simultaneously
you need separate laws to handle
separate issues
but not so said the bureaucrats if a
school is not doing enough according to
the bureaucrats to root out and punish
sexual harassers then they're
discriminating based on sex and they're
out of compliance with title ix it was
decided
but what is sexual harassment exactly
how do you define it
and and how should schools be punishing
it
if we're talking about criminal
harassment shouldn't this be left to law
enforcement and the criminal courts to
adjudicate
lots of ambiguity was created and
totalitarian bureaucrats as we know love
nothing more than ambiguity soon sexual
harassment had become a category
encompassing a wide range of speech
and the alleged sexual harassers were
being tried and convicted in these title
ix kangaroo courts and these extra
judicial tribunals without any
opportunity to defend themselves or face
their accusers there was no evidentiary
burden put on the accusers someone is
just accused that the kangaroo court
says you're guilty and then their life
is ruined
that was until the trump administration
as an article in the wall street journal
notes quote the high court has been
clear that most speech does not rise to
the level of unlawful sexual harassment
unfortunately before 2020 many
universities routinely use title ix as a
club against protected speech with
northwestern university famously
initiating a title ix investigation
against a professor merely for
publishing an article that offended some
students in 2020
education secretary betsy devos tried to
right the ship by issuing a regulation
that reiterated the legal boundary
between protected speech and sexual
harassment as determined by the supreme
court in davis first monroe county board
of education in that 1999 decision the
court held that a title ix violation
occurs only when the behavior is quote
so severe pervasive and objectively
offensive as to deny the victim access
to education on the basis of sex the
devos regulations sought to enforce that
legal principle
but now the byte administration has uh
leaped into action sensing another area
of existence where they could wreak
havoc and another avenue through which
to inject more misery and confusion into
american life joe biden has as of last
week
officially proposed changes tonight on
to title ix again changes that he by no
means has any legal power to actually
enact but what does that matter
here's the wall street journal on
biden's proposed title ix adjustments
and these this was the the official
proposal that was issued
just last week
it says the buy administration's promise
to repeal the 2020 rule and uh broaden
the definition of harassment would
effectively overturn a supreme court
ruling by administrative fiat ushering
in the return of unconstitutional speech
codes designed to silence dissent the
biden rules are also likely to roll back
due process protections for students
accused of sexual misconduct in the
american legal system accused persons
have a right to receive timely notice of
the accusations against them view
evidence and present their side of the
story to an impartial arbiter but in the
years before the devos regulation many
students had their lives ruined by
campus kangaroo courts in which the mere
accusation of misconduct was sufficient
for punishment nearly 200 of these
students sued their universities for
violating their rights and received
favorable court rulings the devos
regulation required schools to comply
with these legal rulings unfortunately
the buy administration is set to give a
federal seal of approval back to these
college star chambers
but that's not all not even close
the proposed change
delivered by the
the new rule would also quote pretend
this is this is reading from the rule
now
it would protect lgbtqi plus students
from discrimination based on sexual
orientation
gender identity and sex characteristics
so yes gender identity would be a
protected category under title ix
so this piece of legislation that was
written to protect
uh
people against discrimination based on
sex
will be changed
by the executive branch just by
declaring it to add gender identity into
it now
needless to say
the original wording of title ix makes
no mention of gender identity
and that's probably because at the time
of the higher education amendments of
1972 the concept of gender identity had
only just been invented by the pedophile
john money a few years before
none of the people involved with
creating title ix had heard of gender
identity hardly anyone in the world had
heard of it
john money had only recently plucked
this concept out of his fevered
degenerate imagination and was still at
the time in the process of attempting to
verify it through a years-long sexually
abusive experiment on two young boys who
were both driven to suicide
now 50 years later
this incoherent
nonsensical concept invented by the
sexologist
equivalent of joseph mangala
is or will be soon a matter of federal
law
and the effect is that now now the very
accommodations and facilities for women
which title ix was meant to establish
and protect will be taken away
because now
uh according to biden
a man's gender identity as a woman that
is his perception of himself as a woman
is as valid as legally legitimate
as legally protected as a woman's actual
physical identity as a woman
now the department of education
explained in a statement quote
the proposed regulations will advance
title ix goal of ensuring that no person
experiences sex discrimination sex-based
harassment or sexual violence and
education as the supreme court wrote in
both stock versus clayton county it is
impossible to discriminate against a
person on the basis of sexual
orientation or gender identity without
discriminating against the individual
based on sex
the regulations will require that all
students receive appropriate support in
accessing all aspects of education
now that doesn't make any sense even on
the left's own terms
of course they can't really explain what
gender identity is exactly because the
idea itself makes no sense they also
can't explain what sex is or what a
woman is or what anything is anymore but
to the extent that they can say anything
semi-intelligible about gender identity
they are the ones who always insisted
that gender identity is not the same as
sex these are two different things they
claimed
yet now we're told that it's impossible
to discriminate on the basis of gender
identity without discriminating on the
basis of sex how so if the two things
are totally different and separate
well the answer is that they're not
separate things not anymore
they were for years when it was useful
for them to be
they were back when this whole thing was
invented by john money
but now the cause of lgbt rights demands
that gender identity and sex be put on
the exact same footing
a man who says he's a woman must be seen
as a woman in every sense including in
the biological sense
it would hurt his feelings
if any difference at all was
acknowledged this was a move made by
activists a while ago
they have long since collapsed the very
sex versus gender distinction that they
engineered
but now through this title ix change
it'll become a matter of law
women will be officially completely
finally erased as a distinct legal
category
and so will men
i mean neither group exists anymore
we're all squished squished together in
this hazy indistinguishable
muddle all of this for the sake of the
lgbt lobby
they've been given everything they want
for years
and now they want to erase women
officially legally
just the entire category out the window
and
if biden has anything to say about it
they'll be given that too
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well did you know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
uh if nausea is getting in the way of
enjoying life's important moments for
you i've got some good news you gotta
check out relief band relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more how it works is relief
band stimulates a nerve in the wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick so
it's just like the name says it's
legitimately a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea and
you can change the intensity depending
on how you're
feeling and how sick you're feeling you
can make it stronger a week or whatever
you want it's just that simple plus the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects i've been using
relief band for
years now to deal with the car sickness
that i have and everyone knows i don't
go anywhere without my trusty relief
band
by my side and in fact on my wrist so if
you're finally taking that summer trip
that's been on your calendar since 2020
i've got good news for you right now you
can join the over 100 000 relief band
users with an exclusive offer just for
matt welsh listeners if you go to relief
band and use promo code walsh you'll
receive 20 off plus free shipping and a
no quest 30 day money back guarantee
remember it's better to have a relief
band and not need it than to need it and
not have it so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com and use
promo code walsh for 20 off plus free
shipping
all right we begin with uh something
completely horrifying unfortunately this
is uh the latest from cnn it says 50
migrants are believed to have died after
they and others were found in sweltering
conditions in a semi truck in san
antonio a federal law enforcement
official said on tuesday in a scene that
the mayor called a horrific human
tragedy the death toll which the city's
fire chief gave monday as 46 includes
migrants from mexico guatemala and
honduras
according to officials their discovery
monday comes as u.s federal authorities
have launched an unprecedented operation
to disrupt human smuggling networks amid
an influx of migrants at the u.s mexico
border
so
these were
and there's still a lot that isn't known
about this including at least according
to the latest report i read how exactly
these these people died
um
it would seem
apparent that they were just
left locked in this
the back of this truck and just kind of
left and abandoned there
to die i mean an
unthinkable death and there are um many
children who are also a part of the
death toll here
now why did this happen like who's
responsible for it
well the first person responsible for it
is whoever did it like the human
smugglers who brought these people
across and they just left them to
cook to death in the back of a truck
they're
that individual or those people are are
responsible for their own actions
obviously
but can you point the finger anywhere
else well yes you obviously can
um you could point it at the bite
administration
you could point it at the left you could
point at a democrat party
for their open borders
policies
that empower and enable human smugglers
and encourage like enticing human
smugglers to do exactly this
this is what your compassionate your
so-called compassionate
open borders policies this is what it
gets you this is what it leads to
certainly these 46 or 50 people are not
the first uh far from the first i mean
hundreds thousands of people have died
due to these kinds of policies
when we're talking about
illegal immigrants who have died in the
process of being smuggled across
or talking about american citizens who
have died
at the hands of some of the people who
have been uh who've been able to come
across
so here's here's what it comes down to i
think
if you want to avoid these kinds of
unimaginable human tragedies here's what
it comes down to
you have two options
okay when it comes to immigration
one
is to
completely open the borders
have actual open borders like officially
and just announce we don't have borders
anymore they don't exist and uh and so
anyone can come and there's you don't
have to even worry about being a citizen
but none of that exists anymore
maybe stop issuing stop issuing uh birth
certificates and uh birth certificates
are transphobic anyway most of the time
because they say male or female stop
issuing birth certificates stop issuing
social security cards stop issuing
anything like that nobody has official
identification and the country just like
we all just exist on this plot of land
and there is no actual country anymore
so that's that's one thing you could do
and if you do that now i said that these
are options that would avoid and
mitigate these human tragedies there'd
be a lot of of terrible tragedies that
would happen as a result of that but you
wouldn't have human smugglers because
there'd be no reason to smuggle people
across because there is no border to
smuggle them across them
so that's one option
the only other option
to avoid this particular problem
of human smugglers murdering people
is to strictly enforce the borders
so either you just have none at all or
you strictly enforce them
anything in between those two options
you're gonna have this
so then which one should we have
because if you're gonna have borders
then you have to enforce them and if
you're not going to enforce them the
worst possible like the worst of all
worlds is to have the border and not but
not enforce it
um so which one should you go with well
seems pretty obvious to me and not just
to me but to pretty much everyone who's
ever existed and every country that's
ever existed that the latter option is
the one you go with you have borders and
you enforce them
there's never been a country in history
that has just had no borders at all
and not worried about having any kind of
national identity or national
sovereignty at all there's never been a
country that's just given up on that
because there can't be because the
moment you give up on that then you
cease to exist as a country you're not
even a country anymore
and if you're not a country anymore then
there's there's no reason for anyone to
come you you can't offer refuge to
anyone even if you wanted to
so having complete open borders and um
uh
essentially no country at all just
doesn't make any sense that that's
that's the that's the end of the country
that doesn't make any sense
um and if you're worried about helping
immigrants you're certainly not going to
do that if you simply give up on the
country
on having a country
which leaves us with the option of you
have borders and you enforce them
strictly
okay you enforce them with with
men with guns
that's what almost every other country
in the world does
they have borders and they have men with
guns enforcing those borders
patrolling those borders
and that's what we should have
uh
and you do that and you're not going to
have
50
immigrants who are left to cook to death
in the back of a truck
like you send the message out to the
human smugglers don't even try it
okay you try it and we're going to catch
you we're going to make your life a
nightmare
i mean if you're really serious about it
you know what you would do
one thing you would do is you would have
a
mandatory sentence
capital punishment execution for human
smugglers
you really want to get serious about it
that's what you would do
you try to smuggle people across the
border um given that human smugglers are
some of the worst human beings on earth
and
obviously a clear and present danger
to innocent people women and children
then you you send the message we catch
you smuggling people across we're going
to convict you of the crime and then
we're going to execute you
in short order
that would actually be the compassionate
thing if you really care about people
that's the compassionate policy
all right let's move uh to this the left
right now is having a hard time deciding
where to direct their rage in hysteria
as we talked about yesterday the supreme
court issued another wildly correct and
necessary ruling on monday reaffirming
the existence of the
first amendment which is good and the
first amendment gives
as we found out in this case it gives a
football coach the right to pray on the
field
with whichever players volunteer to
participate
that is the that's the actual uh
exercise and expression of religion
and you have that right in the first
amendment
uh and as we established yesterday when
a coach kneels on a football field in
praise he is not a member of congress
enacting legislation to establish a
state religion just because a coach is
praying on the field that doesn't mean
that's the state religion and everyone
has to do it
so he has the right to do that um and
that came of course on the heels of the
dobbs decision which came directly on
the heels of the decision affirming our
second amendment rights so there's a lot
of outrage to go around for the left and
they're taking sort of a machine gun
approach and spraying these talking
points all over the place just to see if
it hits any target uh one talking point
they've settled on for the religious
liberty case is this
and uh we have a few examples of it so
here just from from twitter accused
pulled a few examples and this this
talking point is all over the place
nancy armor says this is and reacting to
the supreme court decision about the uh
coach praying on the field
this is to put up politely bs if he was
a muslim or jewish coach you can be sure
the ruling would have been different
and then what else do we have there's
there's a bunch of them uh
michelle fate says in case you were not
convinced already that we're living in a
theocracy you know this would not have
gone down this way if the coach was
muslim or jewish or catholic
holy uh s supreme court sides with coach
who sought to pray after the game okay
so there's another one it wouldn't have
happened
uh this is an interesting this is a
political cartoon in the washington post
and it says if you're okay with this and
then you see a picture of a coach
praying on the field then you should be
okay with this
and then uh it's a picture of this is a
satanist coach who's not praying but he
set up
satanic iconography uh and uh and
candles and stuff on the field so if
you're okay with having
the coach pray then you should also be
okay with like a satanic ritual in the
middle of the football field
so that's a similar talking point jameel
hill always
has a
great insight to offer says the issue
wasn't about him praying but that he was
pressuring other students to join him
please let a muslim coach try this and
see what happens
okay so you get the idea now
ben wexler who i think is a comedian
allegedly says
i bet this ruling wouldn't have gone
this way had it been muslims or jews
okay so we get the idea
if this was muslims if if the if if this
coach was jewish
totally different the supreme court
would have ruled against him
conservatives would be rooting against
him
now this line is monumentally stupid for
a number of reasons
one of those reasons is that in the
decision on monday in the actual
decision itself if you read the decision
they actually specifically mention the
religious rights of muslims they mention
and affirm the religious rights of
muslims in the language of the decision
also the court has in the last few years
in an opinion i believe that was written
by scalia
an eight to one decision just a few
years ago defended the religious rights
of muslims
saying in that case that a muslim woman
was discriminated against because she
wasn't allowed to wear uh her
hijab at work she was working at
abercrombie and fitch because
abercrombie and fitch apparently still
exists
so
we know that that's false because we
have a recent example of the supreme
court ruling in a case that had to do
with the religious rights of muslims and
in that case rather than a to three
decision it was an eight to one decision
in favor of her
so actually the the truth is the other
way around
um
because it was a christian this was a
six to three decision
if it was a muslim recent history shows
us it would be a unanimous or at a
minimum an eight to one decision
so that's one reason why this talking
point is really stupid
uh
the other reason is that
once again the left shows that they
simply do not understand their
opposition
and as we've talked about recently they
don't understand us
uh they they assume that we're like them
in that we see everything through a
racial and ethnic lens we judge
everything through we you know we also
have this intersectional identity
politics thing of our own and that's how
we judge everything
and before we decide
whether someone is right or wrong in
behaving a certain way we need to know
their skin color uh their specific
religion their ethnic background their
sexual orientation all that kind of
stuff but no that's not how we operate
it's just not that's not how we see the
world
in fact
the reason we have these stark divisions
one of the main reasons in this country
is that we don't see the world that way
so you've got two sides who it's not
just that they disagree on the issues
they see the world they view the world
through dramatically different lenses
so in fact
they may shock the left to discover this
but we actually care about religious
liberty
like we actually just believe in it
that's all
we believe that if you are the member of
a religion
that you have the right to practice that
religion
and yes you can do it on a football
field because why couldn't you
would i be okay with a muslim praying on
a football field
yes why wouldn't i be okay with that i
assume that that this has already
happened i assume that there are plenty
of muslim athletes out there at every
level of sports
and in every sport and i assume that
they probably pray on the field or on
the court
great
why would i care about that
that's it
we believe that people have the right to
express their religions
i think the other thing is that on the
left
you know they
uh
there are so many euphemisms
and
whatever they're saying on any given
issue
it's like they don't they don't actually
believe what what they're saying is that
they decide what they believe based on
the circumstances and it's this is a
consequence of being a relativist that
there is no real objective truth or
anything like that um there's certainly
no objective morality
uh or anything approaching that
and so what is true uh and what it what
is factually true and what is morally
correct changes depending on the
circumstance
and so that's another reason why they
look at us talking about religious
liberty and they simply cannot believe
that we actually just believe in
religious liberty no matter who
is the one
enjoying
that right
but we do
we actually do
all right camila harris gave her first
interview after the road decision and
she was as eloquent as you might expect
let's listen to that
i couldn't believe it um
because they actually did it and and
here's what they did
they the court actually
took
a constitutional right that has been
recognized for half a century
and took it from the women
of america
that's
shocking
when you think about it
in terms of what that means
in terms of democratic principles in
terms of the ideals upon which we were
founded about liberty about freedom
um you know i thought about it as you
know a parent we have two children who
are in their 20s a son and a daughter
i thought about it as a godparent of
teenagers
i thought of it as an aunt of of of
preschool children and a woman yourself
and a woman myself
and the daughter of a woman
and a granddaughter of a woman
and you know my husband and i are
actually talking about it we have a 23
year old
and my mother-in-law is in her 80s
our daughter
will not know the rights for the court
for the amount of time that my
mother-in-law knew these rights
which is the right
that
that should be
well settled
that a woman should have to make
decisions about her own body
and when we think about it everyone has
something at risk on this
i have never heard
such a shocking and appalling
uh
transphobic rant
a mem from someone in the white house
from the vice president of the united
states
to sit there and simply
erase
pregnant men
uh the most marginalized community
in the world are pregnant men
and she embraces them from existence
i'm i'm appalled and i i really hope
that
members of the uh trans community
members of the the lgbt community such
as myself as an lgbt uh children's
author of course um i hope that we can
all remind camille harris the the vice
president that
uh
all everything she just said it you can
that's gone now that is done that's
finished
all of that is done so you you need to
recalibrate here i know this is the way
that you're used to talking about this
issue but that is done now on your side
anyway
so you got to figure out a different way
of approaching this
i mean that she would have the gumption
to sit there
and say
i mean not only is she saying that this
is an issue that only affects women
because only women get pregnant
um which is which is nothing but
transphobic that's a tr it is a
transphobic conspiracy theory that only
women get pregnant number one
but for her to even say
so
casually
that she's a woman
oh as a woman myself how do you know
you're a woman
how do you know that
i mean the way these things are defined
these days in fact they're not defined
at all
i find that to be quite
quite shocking
uh in fact lots of famous and
semi-famous people have been chiming in
about this we have another one here's a
if you're ready for some comedy it's
been a little heavy so far in the show
so let's let's do some comedy i think a
little bit of a comedic relief um wanda
sykes who's a famous comedian
she was on with stephen colbert another
famous comedian they're doing it's a
late night show
this is a time to just you watch late
night shows you kick back you relax you
have a good laugh is all and so here is
a little bit some more great comedy
from uh from stephen colbert on the late
show listen
how are you doing how are you doing i'm
a black gay woman and i have a daughter
so i'm not doing so well right
little now you're a little salty i'm a
little salty right now okay yeah yeah
we'll sprinkle a little salt yeah
let's put some flavor on here sucks man
it it really does i mean you know it's
like the
the country it's no longer a democracy
right i mean we're
it's no longer a majority rule
no certainly not the senate certainly
yeah the representation from the supreme
court it's not it's not it's no longer
majority rule and and i mean it's like
the these judges that just
they basically lied when they were you
know being during their confirmation
hearings right yeah
especially kavanaugh
yeah
so how you how can you be a supreme
court justice and you just you're just
lying you know what they had their
fingers crossed or something or what i
mean
it's yeah it's it's just it's just a
bunch of horse it really is
[Applause]
well to me it's like the problem is that
middle stuff is it's those states in the
middle that that that red stuff
why they get to tell us what to do when
the majority of us live
out you know new york california and
we're paying for all this crap really i
mean right
great comedy is always from the late
show stephen colbert i mean in a certain
way it is great comedy and uh also it
gives us it gives us some more insight
into the mindset
of the elitist liberal because
everything you just heard there was was
confused garbled
um here is
what we find this this
mix this very potent mixture of
rampant stupidity
mixed with this snobby
dismissal you know this self-important
dismissal of the majority of the country
so on one hand she's like oh the red
stuff the re she's talking about human
beings by the way those are human beings
if you're if you're if you disagree with
her if you're a conservative then you're
just red stuff gets just get rid of it
sweep it away just yeah whatever
just maybe just send in send in that the
the troops just you know just get rid of
them ship them off somewhere
uh that's how she views
most of the country
red stuff
and while she's saying that she's also
revealing that she
she does not understand at all how our
system of government actually works
so you say it sounds it's like what is
it what happened to majority rule
this is a supreme court decision wanda
it's majority rule on the court
okay but that's not how
court the supreme court they don't take
a poll
of
americans and then decide based on that
that's just not how the supreme court
works
and by the way just see a no
if they if things were decided that way
um we would not have what you want which
is
abortion from
you know legal abortion from
uh moment of conception all the way till
birth
because it's only a very small sliver of
the most deranged and bloodthirsty and
morally debased americans like like
wanda sykes and others
who
favor that
so you wouldn't actually want majority
rule
in the first place
uh but either way that's not how the
supreme court makes decisions
but as we know um
when institutions like we talked about a
couple days ago
institutions are broken
they don't work anymore
they need to be
reformed or
destroyed incinerated and rebuilt
when they stop doing what the left wants
the moment they fall out of line out of
step
with what the left demands they're
broken that means they're broken now and
they have to be
we have to get rid of them throw them in
the wood chipper that's that's the
attitude yeah i want to play one other
thing for you actually a couple of
things before we get to the comment
section um so again we've got you know
women especially especially famous women
in this case a nominally famous women
woman
telling their abortion stories in
response to rose so here's ireland
baldwin who's the daughter of famous
gunman alec baldwin telling her own
story um and she starts for some reason
talking about the time she was raped and
she she did not conceive a child during
the rape so that the rape had nothing to
do with
the abortion whatsoever but she starts
by talking about that and then
eventually she gets around to talking
about the time she actually conceived
through consensual sex and then decided
to abort i want you to listen to the
reason that she gives listen
flash forward to another point in my
life when i did have a boyfriend and i
did become pregnant
at that point in time i would say we
were very unhappy together and
he made it pretty clear that he never
wanted kids or marriage um he barely
wanted to be in a serious relationship
i chose to get an abortion because i
know exactly what it felt like to be
born between two people who hated each
other
could i have had that baby and put that
baby up for adoption maybe maybe not
but choosing to raise a baby without my
own financial security
uh without a loving and supportive
partner
that wasn't gonna work for me
i chose me and i would choose me again
it's your life it's your choice
now this is great i mean the reasoning
everything you heard there is not great
but the fact that she's saying this
is great and um i want more feminists
and pro-abortion women
to be honest and uh and say this kind of
stuff out loud
because people need to hear it
you know the the vast majority vast vast
majority of abortion in this country
they have nothing to do with rape
nothing to do with life of the mother
anything like that
uh these these very rare
cases like that it's nothing it's just
exactly what you heard there um it's
someone who
that had consensual sex got pregnant and
uh you know could i put it up for
adoption yeah maybe maybe not
what do you mean maybe maybe of course
you could have put the child up for
adoption yeah i just didn't feel like it
i didn't feel like it answered that's
what she said i i
didn't feel like
giving birth to the child
and going through the process put him up
for adoption and so uh just killed the
child because i chose me
and that is
the
pro-abortion argument
okay you you whittle everything else
away get rid of all the euphemisms
everything else all the talking points
all the propaganda cut all of that
bs away and what you're left with is
exactly what you just heard there i
chose me
and there's
quite a bit of incoherence mixed in
because she also says well i i know what
it's like to be born
to parents who don't want me
okay well that's that's terrible that
you were born in that you were that you
lived in that situation as a child and
it sounds like your parents are pretty
awful in fact we know that they're awful
people
but
yeah but you're you're happy that you're
alive though right
so you were born into a terrible
situation
um
but you're still living i mean you
haven't you haven't killed yourself
thank god and so clearly you're happy to
be alive and not only are you happy to
be alive but you but your life is as you
attest your life is extremely important
in fact you believe that your life is
more important than anything your life
is so important that it comes above the
life of your own child you could you
could kill your life according to you is
so important
that you could kill your own child just
to protect your own convenience and your
own lifestyle
and that is in spite of the fact
that you were
essentially as you say an unwanted child
tragically
so what does that tell us it tells us
that
even if a child is born into a situation
like this
they are still
worth
something
they have they not worth something they
have infinite value because it's a human
life
all the same
can't expect her to connect those dots
though all right one other thing billy
joe armstrong who apparently still leads
the band green day he's like 50 years
old
i can see him right there oh that's a
sad sight
so he's this out of shape 50 year old
dude still wearing eye makeup and hair
dye
still singing angsty breakup songs that
he wrote when he was you know 17.
and anyway he announced during a show i
think this is in the uk he announced
that he's renouncing his his citizenship
because of the row decision and he's
given up on america let's listen to that
[Applause]
stupid in the world
now you know the great thing is that
armstrong lives in california
which has no abortion restrictions at
all
so so now in protest he's gonna move to
the uk i guess so
in in protest he's gonna move from a
place where there are zero abortion
restrictions to a place that has
abortion restrictions makes a lot of
sense but never mind that uh i'm just
devastated that he's leaving
just like i was devastated yesterday by
the you know the twitch streamer who i
who i forgot her name already but
um oh pokemane
first pokeman leaves
you know you wake up one morning and
pokeyman is nowhere to be found
she has left all of us behind
in the dark in the cold crying out
and then the next day you find out that
billy joe armstrong is also leaving
think about i want you to really think
about this because you think you might
think it's a joke but it's not
think about all the great music
that he's made in the last
25 years let's say
and now we're going to be deprived of
that in this country
think about all the great songs that
green day has made in the last 25 years
so many great songs
like um
well you know there are a lot of them
i'll think more about that and we'll
we'll get to the comment section
do you know their name
you know with the ever increasing number
of uh makes and models that are out
there it's impossible to stock all the
car parts that you need in a traditional
stain chain storefront why endure often
pointless or intimidating frankly
terrifying questions that you may hear
from the counterman uh if you go to the
to the auto parts store why deal with
any of that you could just go to
rockauto.com at home uh or you could
just pull your phone out of your pocket
and go to rockauto.com it's as simple as
that rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they have everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are reliably low and the
same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers so why spend up to
twice as much for the same parts go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck remember as
always to write walsh in their how did
you hear about us box so they know that
i sent you
uh the free jay says that interpretive
dancer they hired to play matt is pretty
impressive
a lot of
comments like this so there is this
speaking of conspiracy theories there's
this conspiracy theory that has
started in the comment section you know
on among the sweet baby gang who i
thought were above this sort of thing
but the conspiracy theory is that
for the interpretive dance that i
performed for you yesterday in
celebration of having a million
subscribers on youtube that it wasn't
actually me
um so what do you what do you think you
think we
hired an interpretive dancer to hide
behind this screen right here and then i
just walked out and he performed the
dance while i hid behind the screen you
think
that would be such a weird bizarre thing
to do
and uh no that's that is a dance
that i'm not going to say that i
choreographed it because there was no
choreograph it was me
in in a in a pure ecstatic
spontaneous moment of joy expressing
myself through the power of dance
and for you to disregard that and claim
that it wasn't even me dancing is just
it's deeply offensive to me and hurtful
um rob says damn matt can dance like an
angel absolutely majestic and anyone who
thinks this isn't him is a bigot thank
you rob
uh ethman says matt's dance was so good
it caused him to
lose his beard another part of the
conspiracy theory so every time it's a
conspiracy theory right you have people
they they're picking up little uh little
what they think are breadcrumbs here and
there and they're kind of stitching it
together pattern kind of doing this
pattern matching thing
and so part of the conspiracy theory is
that
while i was dancing i didn't have a
beard and then but you know but i do
have a beard and i think i can't explain
you know there are a lot of weird
optical illusions that happen i can't
explain it
but i what i like to think is that my
dance was so
beautiful that i was
almost transformed in that moment to
appear to be almost an entirely
different person
that's how i explain it
uh bijan says i really like your views
on some subjects you but you have no
right to determine what's right for a
woman though if you have a daughter and
she got raped then pregnant
you think that's a gift from sky daddy
okay uh of course as always the
pro-abortion person going right to make
it as personal as possible and uh going
right to the hardest possible cases so
the first thing i would say to you is
why are you going right there
like before we talk about the one
percent of cases can we talk about the
99
what about the 99 percent of cases where
there is a consensual activity that
results
in a child and then the child is killed
as a form of birth control
why don't you want to talk about that
and as for the cases of rape once again
you know
um
do you believe
that a person should be punished to the
point of death
for the manner in which they were
conceived
so a child is conceived in
rape and we're going to dole out
punishments
sounds great to me punish the rapist
but you want to punish the child
for the manner of of that child's
conception
which she had
no choice in
that to me is what doesn't make any
sense
um
andrina says matt you're such a role
model for what i hope my sons grow up to
be like
so you want your sons to grow up to be
professional interpretive dancers
apparently which is i think is a great
goal for any child
um
the best backpacker says matt is losing
touch there are several tremor sequels
get with it matt yeah i didn't say
anything that would
suggest otherwise in fact i i actually
think i was thinking about this the
other day it just so happens i was
thinking about tremors
and um there are very few
movies where the sequel is better than
the original i actually think the set
the tremors ii
um is uh is better than the original
but you're not gonna you're not gonna
outdo me in a discussion about tremors
okay i've seen the whole series and we
could talk about if you really want to
talk about it we can
uh victor says how did matt say dick's
head without skipping a beat or cracking
a smile pure professional i'm a lesser
man i don't know what you're talking
about
there was no joke meant there at all i
was talking about the
the dick's head it was the ceo
of the company dicks that's all i was
trying to say tomorrow night june 29th
is backstage live it's our biggest live
event of the year once again we're at
the historic ryman auditorium in
nashville for what will be historic
night for sure and if you didn't see
last year's event well uh just check out
this is a nice preview for what's to
come watch welcome to the daily wire
backstage live at the famous ryman
auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
tune in to live stream to the live
stream tomorrow at 8 p.m eastern
dailywire.com ryman to join me ben
shapiro michael knowles andrew clavin
and god king jeremy boring as we dig
into the political and cultural issues
of the day we have some big wins this
year with projects like my documentary
what is a woman that exposed how dark
the gender affirming movement really is
and there's also our new western
thriller tara on the parry starring gina
carano but these wins are only possible
because people like you have joined us
in the fight so go to dailywire.com
walsh to get 25 off your new membership
today and don't forget to tune in to
backstage live at the ryman tomorrow at
8 pm eastern to find out what's next
here at the daily wire you don't want to
miss it now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well if you want to know the shape of a
culture all you need to do is look at
its art
and we know that by this metric just as
by you know literally any other metric
the shape of our culture is less a shape
and more an oozing decaying lump of
putrid sludge
you could come to this determination of
course by witnessing the art
quote-unquote produced by the music
industry or hollywood but perhaps that
would be unfair because modern pop music
is god-awful and stupid and ugly and bad
the auditory equivalent of the stuff
that leaks out of an overflowing septic
tank
but then again it's not really trying to
be anything more than that
pop music barely qualifies as music just
as hollywood cinema barely qualifies as
cinema so maybe for a fairer and more
accurate test we should look at the sort
of art that's actually applauded and
hailed and promoted as art
you know what what art do we celebrate
and hold up as especially beautiful and
meaningful
well
we already know that uh if we look at
the sorts of modern art exhibits and
paintings which attract crowds to art
museums and sell for millions of dollars
to wealthy people who want to look
intelligent or simply launder money or
both the situation doesn't improve very
much
anybody could vomit onto a canvas and
call the piece
vomit on a canvas and sell it for 86
million dollars that's the state of
modern art
so then perhaps maybe we leave that sort
of art to the side and forget about pop
music or hollywood and all that
and look instead
to poetry
you know that's a very pure art form and
maybe this will be our bright spot
or maybe not
because unfortunately with all due
respect to my guys takashi 6 9 and push
isd our most famous living poet in
america is a woman by the name of amanda
gorman now in 2017 gorman was named the
first ever national youth poet laureate
of the united states a couple years
later she was invited to to deliver a
poem at joe biden's inauguration then
she became the first poet to ever
perform during the super bowl and
shortly after that she released a book
of poetry called the hill we climb
and which i think is also the name of a
miley cyrus song as it just so happens i
could be wrong about that but anyway and
then she became
the first poet ever in history to debut
as a number one best seller
at least on usa today but i think across
the board
now
this is all in spite of the fact that
she is
really really really bad
at poetry
her award-winning best-selling
nationally applauded and recognized
poetry sounds like something that a
bored and angsty seventh grade girl
might scribble on the on the dividers in
her three-ring binder during algebra
class or something if kids still use
three ring binders anyway i don't know
gorman writes a bit like dr seuss
if dr seuss was a female and a feminist
and had a fraction of his charm
intelligence and creativity
so maybe she doesn't really like dr
seuss at all on second thought uh the
better analogy might be a woke
self-important fortune cookie
and her twitter page with 6.1.6 million
followers is just pockmarked with cringy
half-rhymed cliches for example on june
24th the poet laureate tweeted
quote
it's more important than ever
that we come together
wow amazing
you know
some aspiring poets might be influenced
by shakespeare or edgar allan poe or
john milton but amanda gorman seems to
primarily be drawing her inspiration
from the inspirational slogans on gift
shop keychains
and back on back on june 1st
she had some more stunning insight when
she tweeted quote
this may be how things have been
but not how they have to be
the only question that one raises is
whether amanda gorman is influencing
kamela harris or is the other way around
yet none of these gems come close to the
great heights that gorman reaches when
composing poetic odes to infanticide
gorman in keeping with her poetry style
seems to choose the ugliest and dumbest
side of every issue
which of course means that she's rabidly
pro-abortion and in the lead-up to
robbing overturn
gorman went viral with a pro-abortion
rant that i can only speculate is
supposed to sound a little bit like
poetry let's listen to a bit of that
eight reasons to stand up today against
abortion bans in the united states one
let's get this straight when the penalty
for rape is less than the penalty for
abortion after the rape you know this
isn't about caring for women girls it's
about controlling them two through
forcing them into motherhood before
they're ready these bands steadily
sustain the patriarchy but also chain
families in poverty and maintain
economic inequality three pregnancy is a
private and personal decision and should
not require the permission of any
politician for for all time regardless
of whether to crime women have and will
always seek their own reproductive
destinies
now it may sound like she's simply
plagiarizing from the pro-abortion
talking point she found in the comment
section of a feminist blog
but it counts as as poetry
because she moves her hands around a lot
when she says it so i could
actually every monologue on this show
could be i could be my i could be poet
laureate
delivering poetry every day just by
moving my hands a lot
as i'm delivering
the monologue
now as for the substance of her of her
claims to the extent that we can use the
word substance to describe anything that
she says or does
it should simply go without saying that
uh she's she's making things up it's not
true that the penalty for abortion is
worse than the penalty for rape at the
time she said that there was no penalty
for abortion because roe had not yet
been overturned now that it has been
there still will be no penalty in many
states and in the states where abortion
will be banned i'm not aware of a single
one that plans to instate harsher
penalties on women who get abortions
than they do on rapists
and if this fictional scenario were to
ever come to fruition
the way to correct it would be to make
the punishments for convicted rapists
more severe
personally you couldn't make them too
severe for my taste
either way the crucial point here is
that there should be no penalty for
being conceived by a rapist least of all
should it carry the penalty of death
punish the rapist don't punish the baby
but that's not all that gorman had to
say about this topic on the day row was
overturned she published this
masterpiece which has been clearly you
know something she's been working on for
many months
honing and crafting
though she still forgot to run through
spellcheck before posting it but here's
the poem
we
will not be delayed
we will not masquerade
to the tale of a handmaid
we will not let roe v wade slowly fade
because when we show up today
we're already standing up
with the tomorrow
we made
i made it a little better with the hand
movements she spells handmade the way
that you uh spell it if you were
referring to a sweater that your
grandmother knitted for you
now it's possible that she meant it that
way
like maybe she's talking about
this has something to do with etsy like
things i don't know but but i think we
can assume that she was trying to refer
to the handmaid's tale
and that's obviously the most trite
cliched overplayed and boring thing to
do when discussing abortion so we can be
sure that gorman intended to do just
that of course the line we will not be
masquerade to the tale of a handmaid no
matter how you spell handmade makes no
sense at all i'm not sure that gorman
understands what the word masquerade
even means never mind also that roe v
wade didn't slowly fade but in fact was
dispatched all at once through one
glorious supreme court decision
i understand that she chose all these
words because they rhyme
not because they're true or makes sense
but as unintelligible as her word salad
is it could never be less coherent or
explicable
than her status as an acclaimed poet in
the first place
a status which is now i must say
summarily
stripped from her
because
she is cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike cormina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show democrats
search for answers after roe vs wade is
overturned generation z reconsiders a
life of promiscuity and hedonism to the
media's consternation and the supreme
court upholds religious freedom again
that's today on the bench shapiro shall
give it a listen